hey everyone this is Mike Russo with
GameSpot I'm here with my colleague meg
downy and we are chatting with filmmaker
Alex garland of course this is part of
GameSpot's play for all charity event
we're raising money for black lives
matter and coronavirus relief links for
all that are in the description below
but we're just gonna get into it with
Alex so hi Alex it's awesome to be
speaking with you Louis thank you for
yeah of course
so you've created so many awesome things
over the years ex machina annihilation
devs on Hulu on FX or FX on Hulu rather
and we're gonna talk about all that but
we also know that you're a big fan of
games so we wanted to talk to you a
little bit about that first off we know
that you have Dark Souls of course we
were big fans of devs and so we enjoyed
the Dark Souls shout out in that show
and I made many references to it
throughout our breakdowns but I was
wondering what are your other favorite
games all right I'm gonna I'll just pick
three I shot one I think is a
spectacular fascinating game last of us
is maybe a pinnacle of narrative
storytelling and both Bioshock and last
of us fantastic gameplay in both of them
but hit something very special with
storytelling that shows what the medium
is capable of and then for the third one
I will be obscure because it truly is
one of my favorite games of all time I
was game called tempest 2000 and both of
you are too young to remember it it was
a version of tempest which was a sort of
reflex game you were like a kind of
spider thing moving around a vector
tunnel shooting stuff as it came up it's
a pure reflex game and then there was a
system that Atari released just before
they they died as a console maker called
Jaguar and a very weird sort of
psychedelic guy called Jeff Minter made
his his take on tempest there was called
tempest 2000 and
I that it's got a very very sort of deep
place in my heart in videogame terms
because it is its it is a pure
psychedelic immersive reaction based
experience and video games when they
tell stories are really wonderful but
there's something else video games to do
as well which is about something
hypnotic and you know to give a more
modern example that you know someone
might have actually played would be a
game like rez similar kind of vibe I
guess but tempers to thousands more kind
of stripped down brutal version I guess
I think my version of that is probably
beat saber I was just about to say that
sounds like a rhythm game like a modern
in-game yeah you just hours disappear
into it mm-hmm yes it's a and also that
there was a I don't know I could talk
about games alive happily talk about
games instead of devs actually these
people one of the things that interest
me about games is the is the different
forms of multiplayer there are so
there's a version of multiplayer which
happens a lot these days where you're
hooked up and you've got your ear East
and you're playing whatever it is called
you to but there's another version where
there's a group of people who ain't
gamers and there's sat in the same room
and they each turn takes a relatively
short amount of time so to be the level
takes maybe a minute and a half you've
got to play incredibly well during that
minute and a half and if you've got
three people who are really really
really into video games and they're
trying to crack this thing and there's
limited lives and the pressures on and
you're handing the controller between
you is sort of magical I love that yeah
I mean that's an experience that's
currently lost but hopefully we'll get
it back someday yeah oh yeah the idea of
like the land party when you would have
to bring your council to someone else's
house and then like set up a divider to
make sure that you weren't cheating off
in the other screen in the distant past
of last year when I definitely did that
for my birthday how excited are you
about last of us - very
I had it on pre-order and then they sort
of canceled the pre-order I guess
delaying it and now it's back again what
is it
20th or something it comes out yet soon
and the reviews are in it sounds like a
banger I haven't read any reviews I'm
gonna go into it cold okay I won't say
any more yeah I'm gonna love it I mean
did you check out the trailer for the
Demon Souls remaster no I actually only
heard about it yesterday from a I had to
pick up my son and his friend and the
car was talking about it that's how I
found out
I mean I'm psyched yeah I mean that was
those pre dark souls of course but to me
it's classic oh my god okay well you
have to play you've worked on some games
of course enslaved Odyssey to the West
DMC you know I only really worked on in
slave oh yeah mm-hmm that's interesting
is that something you want to continue
doing do you wanna keep working on games
I would love to I I've always been sort
of like Oh years ago I kind of knocked
on the door of the industry and I said
hey is there any way I could get in and
there wasn't really and I think some of
the stuff I was saying about narrative
potential was probably the wrong time to
be talking in those terms in fact there
was a period or there was a sort of
school of thought within game it was
very very anti narrative they were
saying no no no that's what film and
television and books and feared to do we
don't do that we're a different thing
and we're gonna keep what's special
about us so I couldn't I couldn't get
any traction back then or at least I
couldn't with the people I spoke to and
then I tried a few times the only time
I've ever really worked on something was
was with ninja theory on enslaved and
I'd love to do it again I keep it's like
I keep waiting for the call but it never
turns up one day so I can't help but
notice you have a switch on your desk
right behind you are you playing animal
crossing or are you playing
yes oh yeah Oh perfect you can't give us
the the virtual Island toy I'll show you
yeah please
can you see that on the screen a little
yes I might yeah that's that's my
daughter's face which I very very
carefully drew out on the little pixel
you know the little huh you didn't cheat
it with like a generator you can like
upload it onto that website no no that's
her I can't bless someone else has done
a QR code of my daughter which I find
very very sinister so yeah I actually
love Animal Crossing my I play it with
my daughter she's got it on the switch
and I've got a switch and visit each
other's Islands and she she gives me
stuff and I give her stuff and and I
really I really really enjoy it and one
of the things about being friends is
that you get to see how many hours the
other person has clocked up anything she
freaked out the other day because I had
more than 300 hours and she was just
saying bad come on I'm a nice yet she
knows like about 100 less than me yeah
yeah and I'm 50 and then and I just and
Animal Crossing hasn't even been out
that long so I've really been I've
really been working hard they're my
island is in great shape
have you been terraforming and making
sure you have everything exactly oh yeah
now my violins good if it would stand up
to one of those because she she goes
online on like YouTube whatever and you
walk around they show other people's
islands mm-hmm my island would stand up
to inspection on one of those youtube
channels I'm sure of it
so now I have to ask do you have a
favorite villager uh yes I do
it's a little dot pom-pom it's just a
tiny very very sweet little dot I have
asked you your opinion on something
also related to games there's there's
been you know the stigma about game
adaptations for so long
I feel like there have been some
unusually good ones recently meg and I
are both on the entertainment team here
at GameSpot of course and Sonic the
Hedgehog this year The Witcher last year
kind of weirdly you know successful
well-received etc for her game
adaptations like where do you think what
even game adaptations are headed as a
person with kind of a foot in each
industry the the way that the industry
has failed to make game adaptations work
it's been really interesting to me I've
puzzled over it a lot I wrote a movie
called 28 days later about 20 years ago
which was pretty much a result of
playing Resident Evil so I had what
zombie movies when I was a kid men kind
of forgotten about them and then played
Resident Evil but ah somebody's are
great you know I've forgotten how much I
love zombies so in some respects you
could say 28 days later is a sort of
video game adaptation or it's certainly
heavily inspired by a video game I
there's something but whenever people
got intentional about it something got
lost in the translation it could have
been that the license was so expensive
that it forced it towards being a
certain kind of release and so certain
kinds of cookie cutter approaches were
then automatically applied I honestly I
honestly don't learn actually that's
poor because I'm just now thinking of
quite low budget game adaptations that
were made all I know is there's no good
reason why the industry struggled I
can't I can't quite explain it I do
think that actually we're speaking about
the Last of Us as I understand it HBO
are working on a Last of Us adaptation I
think I'm right about that
that's those of people who I would
expect to get it right Sonic I haven't
seen The Witcher I didn't see I'll take
your word for it
opinions vary but overall they've been
potential yeah yeah I I don't know it
probably at one point it was because of
contempt I think that the people doing
the adaptations didn't understand what
they were adapting maybe just story is a
kind of tacky license so they could just
cash in maybe do could be the most
amazing film I mean it's just it's like
a gift
for a film for some reason when you when
you said contempt images of the Super
Mario Brothers movie popped into my head
you know I was pathetic that was a truly
truly pathetic kind of ugly
small-minded movie yeah it was terrible
John Leguizamo was great in it I will
say that yes he was okay maybe there's
some kind of retro affection for it but
I watched it when it came out it's a
core classic in the way of movies that
are so bad that that they're good I'd
rather a movie that was so good that it
was good you know I mean given a choice
anyway sorry yeah no it's just it's
interesting that that you you know you
wrote 28 days later after playing
Resident Evil and that's the original
Resident Evil you know not not the
remake or the remastered version the
version with them really bad terrible
cheesy cutscenes yeah but it was scary
and you need to you need to kind of
project yourself into the mindset of
someone who grew up look I grew up
playing pong and space invaders and
Missile Command and stuff so by the time
you had 3d graphics it was always kind
of immersive and mind-blowing to me that
was and and I remember playing Resident
Evil and finding it scary and and it was
a fun scary and it reminded me of it was
the same scary that I had
watching Dawn of the Dead yeah I totally
agree I mean I think I think Dark Souls
in many ways is you know all the way
through to blood-borne is a modern
iteration of that right because it's
that there's the the world is horrible
and there's horror tropes in the world
building but then because the gameplay
gets so tense you feel a fear that's
like mechanic's as well while you're
playing it so I can kind of consider
those modern portraits
yeah kind of I know exactly what you
mean that they're highly stressful games
mm-hmm is because if you die at the
wrong moment you could really lose a lot
and if you party in terms of what you're
carrying but also if you get to a
certain point with an ax boss fight and
you're on low energy and they're on low
energy and like that is truly stressful
and then you get this huge rush when you
finally you know do it the only the big
difference for me in Dark Souls I think
the reason I love Dark Souls more than
same Resident Evil actually I really the
Resident Evil games are really fun the
Dark Souls game seems to have is kind of
embedded poetry in them you'll you'll
have some weird bit of dialogue with
some sort of broken soul sack with a bit
of armor outside some doorway or gate
and and it feels like some like you've
drifted into this existential dream and
that I think that's what I really love
about Dark Souls the different spaces
are so imaginative and they they seem to
kind of flow into each other and flow
out of each other and it's very that's
very dreamlike and that I think that's
what I really love about this
I mean it's it they do have this kind of
minimal you're right in that a lot of
the stories is it comes across in these
conversations that last three sentences
right in your character never says
anything at all do you think that a
series like the souls series could ever
work in another medium like you think
somebody should look at adapting that I
can't imagine how you do it Dark Souls
film or TV adaptation because say The
Last of Us it has a particular kind of
narrative thread to do the relationship
between this man and this little girl
and then it's a road movie in a way in
or a road trip and and and so it's quite
easy to see how you would parcel that
out into character development and set
pieces and so on Dark Souls the quality
that makes Dark Souls special is
probably unique to videogames I could
imagine doing a ten minute short for
Dark Souls you know and it wouldn't be
it wouldn't really be a story it would
be like a tone like a sequence of
moments but but it's not a movie it's a
yeah it would be like a ten minute thing
you know doing I can imagine you doing
that I think that's as good as segue as
any to start talking about devs Megan I
of course did the breakdowns for
GameSpot I think it's safe to say that
we both are obsessed with it just by
means of a segue I want to ask you about
the Dark Souls moment I think it's in
Episode two it's after we've meet Jamie
for the first time Lily goes to his
apartment and he's playing Dark Souls
and she kind of wraps on his window at
the moment that he dies were you always
go solo yeah that's true that could be
any moment so so I wanted to just ask
you about kind of getting that Dark
Souls reference in there where the idea
came from and you know why you thought
that um it's it's party just affection
for the game which I'm sure just made
pretty clear but it's all
so that you'd I'd think because it's a
show in part about inevitability and
that's where Jamie's headed we have to
get into spoilers for devs because this
is our first chance to talk to you Alex
since the show ended we have some
questions you know about the show as a
whole but but also you know about the
overall themes about the ending so if
you haven't watched Deb's maybe skip
this part of the video you could use
this time to go and watch Deb's because
it's truly one of the one of my favorite
sci-fi shows I've ever seen so obviously
a lot of work went into building the
technology inside of that show we were
continuously surprised as we pored
through each episode to find that so
many of the theories and the
technologies and the machines that were
shown or discussed had Basie's in in
reality do you think that this sort of
simulated you know digital existence
that ultimately the show leads up to is
is realistic getting this is you know
really coming um I I do think it's
realistic I mean I've got to choose my
words slightly carefully because because
I it's easy to say things that a [ __ ]
might be wrong and slightly wrong in
this context can mean very wrong I think
it's I think it's realistic and as much
as that it is possible and when things
are possible that really does mean they
might happen so you need to take on
board the idea that it might happen
there is currently quite a sort of a
significant school of thought that is
particularly entrenched within the tech
industry which says we are already in a
simulation and I sort of think it's no
surprise that the tech industry with its
own sensible missions would like an idea
that puts it's only workings at the
heart of the working of the universe i I
don't believe that I don't believe we're
already in a simulation but but if you
are able to simulate quantum mechanical
processes which must be
be conceivable at some point then
reality then becomes simulator bull so
so yeah sure
I'm glad you dress that because I
definitely was going to ask ask ask
about whether this in the ear and now
yeah just whether you thought you know
because that's obviously a theory you
know ever since forever but also we
talked a lot I think every breakdown for
each episode of Deb's I brought up the
matrix at least once
you didn't confirmed absolutely
confirmed and kind of speaking towards
the idea of the simulation in like the
logistics that would be inside of that
simulation I have to talk about Katie a
little bit because her story was the one
that really broke my heart at the end
like going through it she was kind of
the villain and I respected her a lot
but then she got admit the end when she
basically had to give everything she had
up and then we don't see her in the
simulation did she exist within it did
her and Forrest just not have the story
that they had or she would exist within
the simulation on a different timeline
and in fact on many different timelines
met many different versions but the
Katie that is the Katie outside
observing that has the knowledge that
that Katie has does not exist within
there the easiest way me to describe it
is the KTM Forester like priests Katie
is a priest without doubt and forest as
a priest with doubt but the priest
without doubts stops forests from doing
the thing that Lily ultimately does and
that's what faith does is it inhibits us
it stops us from asking questions that
we should ask because we're told not to
because that would be a betrayal of the
faith
we'd be letting the faith down by posing
those questions and the the reason I'm
saying that is partly to say that is the
explanation for their actions it's not
the Katie's a bad person or a cold
person if you had the faith that Katie
has if you were that priest with no
doubt
so you had that conviction she's no
she's not killing Linden she's not she's
not killing Sergey or Jamie these are
just the pictures unfolding in the way
they would always unfold and many-worlds
does not change that it just means that
within each of those many worlds they
would unfold in a different way
according to quantum variants and stuff
and and not only that forest and Katie
are working knowingly toward something
that will revive anyone who's dead in
the form that they were before they died
so she is absolved of a certain kind of
moral responsibility but but here's the
thing right because this was the point
of the show you have all these ideas
some of them are philosophical some of
the most scientific some of them are
actually political but none of them
reduced some basic things which is you
just have people and loving daughters
loving boys loving girls sort of loving
friends loving colleagues and feeling
things and what what in a way the reveal
at the end with Katie is that she feels
something you know she cares about
forests she she loves him and would like
him to see you know it's more than just
likes him she would she loves him and
she'd like him to stay with her but more
than that he wants she wanted him to be
with his child and wife so anyway yeah
does that answer is that yeah no that
absolutely does answer it just yeah it
seems she's the one I was very surprised
to get to that point in the show and
find that she was the one who I thought
was making this big sacrifice when it
felt like she was you know she was kind
of the one with nothing to lose there's
nobody's right maybe Kenson he's a thug
it's it's really interesting to hear you
talk about you know katie is the the
priest whose faith cannot be shaken and
for
the one with doubts we talked a lot
about you know why Lily would have the
power to make a choice well it's not
it's not Lily it's it's not just Lily
but but you you have to be it's like
they needed some atheism to be able to
do that well yeah exactly arrives in it
just like you kidding well there's
there's that scene where Katie and
forests are seeing themselves slightly
in the future or something and and you
know she folds her arms and we were
saying we said this a lot you know she
could just put her hands in her pockets
there's nothing stopping her from doing
that but she believes that she won't and
so feels herself unable to yeah because
because there's a critique within this
about some paradoxes within religious
thinking and one of them is to do with
free will actually to do with being us
being punished apparently for an
original sin and regional disobedience
by a god if it's the God is all-knowing
would have presumably moan but that was
about to happen not just just before it
happened but since its inception since
the inception of everything and that
that is a paradox whatever anyone says
and so and and so there is that there's
a bunch of these paradoxes floating
around and and one of them is to do with
the way the kind of grip the faith has
and and what that scene between forests
and Katie is attempting to show is the
way in which faith will close down a
reasonable line of questioning I wanted
to ask you one more question about Katie
and forest
there's the flashback scene that that
Katie is watching when forest
essentially went and recruited her he
lays out a scenario and then he asks her
is that possible
right and one of the things that meg and
I discussed a lot when we were analyzing
and breaking the show down was what is
forests ultimate goal and did that goal
morph and shift over time but the thing
about that conversation is
we never actually heard what forest laid
out for her we just heard the question
is it possible so I was hoping you could
maybe reveal what did forest ask her
it's the goal that the ends up being the
goal but forest is is not forest wants
to be reunited with his daughter he
doesn't want his daughter to be dead
even if he can't reunite with her he
just doesn't want her to be dead so he's
looking for the the promise that
religion gives us which is the there's
an existence beyond the one that we're
aware we're having now and but but the
route to that requires determinism in
order to be able to get that and so so
in a sense everything that all of the
things about determinism all of the
falling they're looking backwards and
they're looking forwards that's not the
intention that is a by-product that
would happen if you were trying to make
a machine within a universe that ran
along deterministic rules
you see what I mean so so it's a
misdirect it looks like this thing is a
prediction device looking forwards and
backwards but it's not it's a
resurrection device well that was one of
our questions as as we were saw as the
mystery was unfolding throughout the
episodes you know we were looking at the
the dead rat that they brought in and
were thinking you know I was making a
lot of guesses going well as he is he
going to sort of bring Amaya back to
life and interact with her through the
screen
meg brought up the Tamagotchi analogy
more than once
but then the the you know inserting
himself into that digital world is not
something that I definitely didn't see
it coming
he he could interact with her on the
screen because once you've got the total
data of someone that is a as long as
you're not a duelist right as long as
you think that the mind and the body and
the soul and the body are not separate
they're all contained within you know
atomic constructions then then you then
he would be able at a certain point if
the machine work to be able to construct
his daughter and then talk to her via
the screen but I don't think I don't
think that's what he wants to do because
that would be in a way a disturbing
thing to do to a child that had all of
the feelings and qualities of an actual
child to say listen you're dead but
you're in a computer that we can still
chat to each other in this way know that
that's not going to be helping anyone
his his minimum hope is that he can
construct a world which is equal to our
world in which she can continue to exist
and and then placing himself within it
is like the best version of that world
however he approaches the project not
wanting to believe in many worlds he is
forced eventually to accept that many
worlds is the correct view of the
universe not the way the universe
functions and that gives him a bitter
pill to swallow
is that there will be worlds where he's
reunited with his daughter in a
wonderful way and there will also
certainly be other worlds where it is
reunited in a not pleasant way in in
actually a very very dark way so he's
never able to get exactly the thing he
wants he's just able to know that thing
does exist somewhere do you see what I
mean
is that your view as well about many
worlds yeah of reality outside the show
yeah I I have no view on it
because because there are there are all
sorts of competing views within
interpretations of quantum physics some
of which is deterministic some which are
not deterministic some are one world
some are many there's also many versions
of many worlds which don't relate to
quantum mechanics they relate to maybe
infinity or lots of different universes
or just just basic maths if there's an
infinite number of chance of sights
happen they're going to repeat so and so
on and so forth i I
within that huge mass at the moment I
keep trying to read about holographic
universes there's another completely
different interpretation there's no way
I can know which is the right one I do
know that some of them appeal to me more
than others on a sort of deep
instinctive level and in some ways I
prefer the many-worlds approach to say
Copenhagen because many worlds provides
an explanation and Copenhagen doesn't so
so I guess I could say that but but
listen I'm a writer
in London I don't know I I read I read
and I watch videos and I talk to people
I'm a layman come on you know yeah I
mean imagine how Megan I felt trying to
figure it out we do it exactly the same
way as me you know but but but knowing
in a way isn't really the point but one
of the things is to just offer these
things up to people you know it's not to
say this is the way the universe is is
to say isn't this an interesting thing
that these people are suggesting and
proposing and talking about and an
aren't their ideas wonderful I have 1
continuity question about dads that I
just need to ask real quick at the end
when he is reunited with his daughter is
there a reason that she is still a young
girl or is it simply too neatly tie a
bow on it in a simpler way as possible
I love that question I love it
the reason she is the age she is is
because that's the age the actress was
because we talked at great length
I knew it was going to disappoint her
and I'm sorry I'm not disappointed at
all no we I mean we we ID'd his Subaru
to try to figure out you know what year
he froze his life you know how long ago
did she die etc etc but you know when we
were working out the timeline to the
film we convinced it all to ourselves to
the shortest time frame we possibly
could to try to allow for that kind of
thing and also realistically allow for
the construction of this machine and
this concrete cube and so on and so
forth but but but the truth is that the
answer is the answer I gave us the
answer hey it's it's it's like that in
film you know there's a scene between
lily and Anton you know sort of misty
spy concrete space with the San
Francisco fog rolling pass that was
intended to be shot on a sunny day with
a beautiful view of the bridge when we
turned up there was fog these things can
subsequently look intentional it's you
at the end in film you have to stick a
camera at something an icon aged a
little girl Meg Cena kick herself if she
doesn't get to ask some questions about
annihilation of Amida you absolutely
like her do you
awesome so I have three major questions
about annihilation and I'm sorry to make
you flashback all the way back to
annihilation but it's one of my favorite
movies if not my favorite movie of all
time
so it's kind of speaking to the idea of
having to point a camera at something
and making these choices these aesthetic
choices I wanted to
know about the scene with Oscar Isaac
basically the most gory scene in the
movie not only that it's set aside by
the fact it's also like a found-footage
moment in an otherwise not found footage
movie and so I wanted to know like why
were those choices made why that level
of gore why that filming technique for
that moment specifically what I'd say is
the annihilation is a very honest movie
and it's honest about
[Music]
awful things to do with self-destruction
and internal head spaces and some
aspects of some internal head spaces are
horrific and they are merciless and
strange and so some of the qualities
within annihilation or merciless and
strange I love that's perfect that's I
mean that's exactly the sort of answer I
would have wanted from that now this
one's a little bit more specific about
the bear I've had conversations with
friends who are equally as obsessed with
the movie as I am about the logistics of
the bears sentience and I'm sorry that
this is incredibly specific there's a
debate about whether or not the bear
intentionally stole casas voice Fox by
ripping her throw it out and was aiming
to give itself a voice or like to become
more human or if that was just a
senseless act of violence so um one one
of the things about annihilation is that
the the place it is trying to aim itself
at is people's unconscious so it's a lot
it's very subjective in itself and it's
also subjective in the way it's intended
to be received and responded to so I can
give my subjective response to that but
I wouldn't want it to be in
contradiction to someone else's
subjective response because that's not
how the film is intended to work in my
intent in my intention it is not
deliberately doing anything it is it is
it is as it were part of a refraction
that then takes on that moment at that
time what I would ask I'm just curious
now did you notice that the house that
the bear turns up to is Lena's house oh
absolutely
yeah and did you see Oscars tattoo on
his chest mhm yeah okay so you've seen
those things and you've seen
echo of shots as well yeah so good I
mean the what what is happening in that
space is things that exist within
people's minds are also becoming
physically manifested not just in an
environment but also then in each other
so or abhorrest or two or whatever
happens to be all or a feeling a memory
so so in it's just annihilation it's
just a very very fiercely subjective
movie that is attempting to be existing
more on a space of the unconscious than
the conscious that's fantastic that was
actually my next question was about the
tattoos and I think you covered it
perfectly with that explanation it was I
wanted to know why they would ever
really addressed you know kind of in the
script but they're obviously so clearly
how do you to address I I think I make
films or TV shows really for only one
kind of person with which which which of
people who are interested in stepping
forwards to the narrative if you don't
step forwards to annihilation or dance
or any of them you'll get like a quarter
of the thing because because a huge
proportion of it is is provided by the
viewer it is an absolute 50-50
participation between the viewer and the
group of people that made it and so so
yeah I mean I I think and I think
annihilation is probably in all the
things I've done it's like the purest
version of that it's the most hardcore
version of that it it's it's as much
about you as anything in the films well
I think it's probably time that we let
you go so I just want to reiterate what
a absolute pleasure it's been speaking
with you I thank you thank you so much
because I can talk about video games and
show my animal crossing
and again I'm gonna put on the show well
you know we can always make more time
for that thank you so much for answering
all of our weird specific nerdy
questions about your work and of course
once again this is part of GameSpot's
play for all where we are raising money
for black lives matter and for covert
relief and once again the information
for that is down in the description
below you can follow us on twitter i'm
rogue cheddar meg is rusty polished and
stay tuned to game spot for more